[Music]
hi everyone judge andrew napolitano here
for judging freedom
today is the day after labor day it's
tuesday september 6
2022.
it's a little after five o'clock in the
afternoon here on the east coast of the
united states
today is our
special judging health day in which we
partner with the great dr joel wallach
who comes on
judging freedom as most of you watching
us now know
and diagnoses individual ailments
and prescribes solutions for them
he is of course an nd
as in
naturopathic doctor
because his field of specialty and it's
beyond a specialty it's a field of
expertise and it's beyond expertise
because he's the best expert
on the planet on this
is using nature
and the body
the body's
internal mechanisms
to help you heal yourself
dr wallach it's always a pleasure
welcome back
to judging health
well thank you for so much of the kind
words judge i really appreciate the
honor to be with you and sharing for
your followers and listeners
uh aka americans and the world
so here we go today
i want you to talk about obesity what is
it
what is it what causes it why do some
people
constantly have the battle of the bulge
so to speak
and others can eat all they want and
they're there they practically have a
six-pack abs in their stomach
the floor is yours thank you sir
okay
well what is obesity well forty percent
of americans are obese
eighteen percent of those forty percent
you know uh
percent are severely obese
um
are males 41.9 are females the
definition of obesity is somebody who is
25 pounds or more overweight over their
body weight
we spend in america each year just to
treat the symptoms of obesity not to
prevent it or cure it but just to treat
the symptoms of obesity the weight gain
we spend 210 to 260 billion with a b 210
to 260 billion dollars a year just to
treat the symptoms of obesity and again
if you're 25 pounds or more overweight
you're obese
so what's the cause
nutritional deficiencies are the cause
not a calorie deficiency but a
nutritional deficiency when you're
deficient in minerals people develop a
behavior called pica you can look it up
in any dictionary p-i-c-a pica when
people have pika they just they'll eat
six eight ten twelve fifteen meals a day
okay because they're missing that
nutrient their body's saying you know
cake hey catch up here you you need to
get this mineral so eat more find that
mineral all right
what is pica is is it an acronym does it
stand for four
four words what does the word mean
uh it means
people eating
um
constantly
ah
okay so like pica is a
behavior efficiency that makes you
hungry and causes you what to want to
eat more than you should and more
frequently than you should that's
correct because your body's telling you
to look for specific things which are
the minerals
okay
and so you can eat a bushel basket full
of food with no minerals in it and 10
minutes later you'll eat another bushel
basket full of food no minerals in it 10
minutes later eat another bushel basket
full of food because your body is
telling you to look for those minerals
okay
and
this is why people have cravings for
salt oh man i just have to have more
salt in my food okay because they're
missing those minerals
so
so this pike of behavior leads to
cravings and not just being satisfied
okay hence overeating
and
it all started really heavily
in 1882 when we went from
wood and coal as fuel to electricity
and that was the big boogeyman okay was
electricity
we actually have a book goes into the
story hell's kitchen
okay the book hell's kitchen it's named
after the district in new york city
named hell's kitchen because every bad
thing in the world happens in hell's
kitchen new york city
it's
having lived in new york for 25 years it
does seem that way yeah
okay and so
that's why we named that book hell's
kitchen because it goes into these
nutritional deficiencies why do people
have nutritional deficiencies now that
they didn't have before 1882.
well up until 1882 the fuel of the world
was wood and coal and people would take
the
the um
ashes which were 98 minerals and two or
three percent carbon and put them in
their gardens for fertilizer boy the
plants in the garden just flourish and
suck up the minerals and people would
eat those garden plants and they get the
minerals that way grandma used to take
wood ashes out of the stove
and coal ashes out of the fireplace
and put them into your food
as a spice but they also had the
minerals in them well when we went to
electricity 1882 suddenly now that all
went away
so i prefer the people get a one of our
books it's called rare urban cures go to
chapter 10 and 11 page 272 starts it
tells you how to collect hair where to
ship it
um
how to understand the results of the
hair analysis there's two charts one
are
the um
60 essential minerals you know calcium
and magnesium and zinc and copper and
all that kind of stuff
and also goes into
um
the um
bad minerals lead and
let's see mercury and
uh uranium and that kind of stuff so the
two different charts okay and so you
know how to fix everything so usually
within 90 days you'll have fixed
everything you're taking all the good
stuff you were missing your we tell you
how to get rid of the bad stuff
and so suddenly now
the pica goes away
and whoever was cooking your meals say
you're not eating dinner i don't know
i'm just not hungry anymore because now
you're getting those minerals and you'll
start losing anywhere from a half a
pound to two pounds a day do they do
does the ingestion
of the appropriate minerals
actually reduce appetite
that is correct
and what particular minerals are we
talking about or are you talking about
the universe of the good minerals which
i think you said was about 60 of them
yeah to to a degree it's the universal
universe of the 60th century minerals
every one of them is required your body
knows it
okay each one of them is required for
something
and
it's one of those things
where
um
you have to avoid the bad foods so it
can absorb the good minerals the bad
foods include gluten wheat powder and
oats so you have to get rid of gluten
your intestines should look like a shag
rub with all the finger like villi
okay they produce some ninety percent of
your absorptive surface a little finger
like villi so when you cut open an
intestine during surgery
or an autopsy or during an anatomy
lesson your intestinal lining looks like
a shag rug because of all these villi
well when you eat gluten wheat polynotes
or you drink gluten
um rye whiskey
beer made from wheat you can have beer
made from rice there's no problem but if
you have beer made from wheat and
drinking rye whiskey oh you have a
problem so wheat wheat is one of the
enemies wheat and oatmeal are the two
worse
because grandma eats oatmeal every
morning for breakfast yes my my mother i
won't tell you how old she is but she's
up there god bless her i think she's
going to make it to 100. she eats
oatmeal every day she's thin as a rail
she's energetic
and she doesn't have a huge appetite but
she eats three meals a day but always
has oatmeal should she i'll tell you her
age at age 97
97 what i would do is have her cut the
volume of her oatmeal
like in half
and
kind of replace it with rice
so one of my one of my best buddies
who's
energetic well-built and athletic he's a
retired uh state trooper he's now the
head of security at a major medical
center had some cardiac issues and he
had a couple of stents put in and the
cardiologist said to him
eat oatmeal every morning
oh
and that's what he does
what's going to happen is he going to
get obese
what's going to happen is he's in a
period of six months people have killed
all those villi and his small intestine
okay with the gluten in the oatmeal and
he can eat all he wants but he won't be
absorbing the nutrition
okay he he'll be absorbing calories but
he won't be absorbing the mineral
nutrients he'll be coming out the other
end okay so it'll go to his
septic tank okay
and so
we do have another book it's called dr
wallace cooking without the bad foods is
300 pages
of gluten-free recipes 300 pages of
gluten-free recipes
and also fried food free cooking okay
and that one flies out the door every
day because everybody hears me say stay
away from gluten well how do you cook
we've been our whole family's been
eating gluten
three times a day forever well here's a
book with 300 pages of gluten-free
recipes and fried food free recipes they
taste good
and so forth so it's not like you have
to wander around yourself and figure it
out we've already figured it out for you
why is it that
some people have pica and others don't
why is it
that some people are just naturally thin
and they eat all they want of whatever
it seems that way they eat all they want
of whatever they want they don't have to
watch what they eat
okay well these are people who are
responding differently to their pica
they are ones who use a salt shaker with
every meal take the top off and put the
salt on their food
okay
um this is why some people go crazy over
salt
because they do have pica
okay and the only minerals they know
about to satisfy that craving
is salt we have a pink himalayan salt
there's 78 minerals in it we've added a
little bit of black pepper to it for a
little zing
and i take um
two teaspoons a day one at breakfast one
dinner time that pink himalayan salt
with 78 minerals in it
and
this is in addition to all the minerals
i'm taking with our products
and so i only eat two mil two meals a
day i only eat two meals a day
uh i weigh 142 pounds i'm five foot six
that way
uh 142 pounds i'm 83 years old and most
people think i'm in my 50s when they
look at me my activity level and so
forth they don't look like i don't look
like i'm 83. i thought you were
significantly younger than 83
significantly and you and i have never
met in person but we have these happy
conversations right now
on judging freedom today judging health
and and we have happy conversations on
the phone and of course i know you by
reputation and we have many mutual
friends who feel the same way about you
that i do but none of them has told me
your age and i never imagined your age
until what you uh just told me yeah
in june i'll be 84. god love you what
what
uh should people
who are 20 or 25 pounds overweight
do
without starving themselves
to get down to a weight that is healthy
happy
and and
enables them to have self-respect for
their bodies okay great question your
honor and of course we've dealt with
that we have what we call
the keto shake it comes in strawberry
and chocolate
and it's a meal replacer it's not to be
added to a meal it's a meal replacer one
meal a day doesn't have to be the same
meal every day but one meal a day a keto
shake or a keto shake
and you'll lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day but you do have to take
our
mineral nutrients according to your body
weight okay again
the um
excuse me um
the
the book uh dead doctors don't lie
uh the book epigenetics i'll have it in
there let's play doctor have him in
there
but you know it's one of those things
where it's very simple
you take
one healthy brain and heart pack for 100
pounds of body weight if you only weigh
120 pounds i divide it up half of those
breakfasts have those dinner if you
weigh 150 160 pounds i'd get two healthy
brand hard packs a full dose of
breakfast for those dinner time
msm
um
one
bottle per hundred pounds of body weight
if you only weigh 110 pounds it's
two
or three of those tablets twice a day if
you weigh 160 pounds or more so three of
those with each meal and they support
and promote means for a pair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the right bone
makes bone surface including the skull
the embossing approach to the skull
and then we have the collagen peptides
which is collagen
from fish poultry sheep and beef that
actually again
rebuilds your bone marrow so you can
build all your immune system including
white blood cells and platelets and red
blood cells and antibodies and stuff
from your bone marrow
let me just remind folks that they can
get all of this by going to
judginghealth.com
uh there's the home page so if you go to
dr wallach and i are partnering in
judginghealth.com
you will see available to you by subject
matter
different
supplements and vitamins vitamins and
minerals in groupings depending upon
your age your weight and what you're
trying to do to and with and for
your body
uh how
uh
obesity how prevalent is obesity in the
country today man if obesity is defined
as
25 pounds or more over ideal weight
then i think obesity is very prevalent
in ourselves it is it's for you're
spending 200 billion dollars a year to
try and cure it and have it
no no
the 260 billion dollars is just spent to
deal with
the symptoms
okay it doesn't it doesn't go to
reversing obesity the 260 billion
dollars just treats the symptoms
okay
it might tone you up a little bit kind
of stuff
but you're not going to get rid of your
obesity by doing what they tell you oh
walk more
eat less well if you're not getting your
minerals that pica
intervenes and you'll eat 10 meals a day
instead i only eat two meals a day i
take so many minerals i'm only having
two meals a day and i'm able to maintain
my weight so let me get this straight if
you take
the right amount and right proportion of
minerals
your body won't crave them
and it won't send signals to your
appetite to eat more that is correct you
get an a plus judge
well i have a good teeth
well 40 of americans are obese they're
25 pounds or more overweight and some of
them i get a lot of people your honor
who are 300 pounds or more
okay i get the big ones of course i've
never had
people who are near the record the
record for women is 1200 pounds
in america uh the record for men is 1400
pounds one time how could a human who's
1400 pounds even stand up and move well
they don't
somebody has to shower them down with a
hose they have to be fed
um
they have to have a toilet on a
wheelchair that's wheeled to them and so
forth uh
okay these are people
in many cases the family puts them in
nursing homes because they just they
can't handle it
okay but it's not unusual for people to
be
um
you know let's say my my height
um five foot six
um 145 pounds is good uh you know i'm an
athlete so i'm very toned
lettered in football and wrestling in
high school and college
okay and so i'm always been an athlete
but when it comes to
um eating i'm not hungry because i'm
taking all these minerals i'm just not
hungry i know i have to have breakfast i
have to have my three eggs at breakfast
my three eggs at dinner time so i get my
cholesterol to maintain my brain 25 of
our brain weight is cholesterol don't
let a doctor give you statin drugs to
lower your cholesterol don't do that
all right
doctor every time we talk
you know i'm pretty well educated but
but as a lawyer and legal scholar not as
a
not as a physician but every time we
talk i learn more from you and i know
from the emails we receive and from the
visits to judginghealth.com
that our viewers do as well it's always
a pleasure
we are going to surprise everybody with
what we'll talk about next time but a
lot of you are commenting to me about
what you want to hear from dr wallach
and we take those comments into account
and of course this is our dr wallach
session for this week but we'll
certainly be back to one
uh next week dr joe joe wallach as
always it's a pleasure thank you for
joining us well thank you so much your
honor god bless you and all the great
things you do for humanity
thank you judge napolitano for judging
health and judging freedom
[Music]
you